wir haben über 30 grad in köln an
welchem tag als heute sollten wir also
besser die hdl sommer folge drehen wir
testen heute gadgets die euch den sommer
alltag oder das grillen im park
erleichtern und gestartet mit dem
bierbike ein produkt ihr seht es schon
dieses ding hier den park tragen wäre
eine absolute schande das haben sich
auch die erfinder des bierbikes gedacht
20k für 30 prozent wollten sie haben das
haben sie bekommen das 1 4 im wert von
66.000 euro was nicht besonders viel ist
ich wunder mich auch warum man sich
dafür dann funding abholt und wenn man
wirklich an die idee glaubt nicht
einfach einen kredit über 20.000 euro
nimmt 30 prozent der firma ist extrem
field soll im prinzip dabei helfen dass
wir den vier kassen auf dem rücken
tragen können das holz gute sache das
ganze erstmal auf
was sind das für bilder alters kann ja
kein mensch erkennen
halleluja so hat mir gesagt hat die
scheiße aufgebaut hat 15 minuten
gedauert verstehe ich nicht warum wir
das nicht einfach so aufgebaut haben und
kombinieren dafür aber ziemlich
kontrolliert dass der kasten natürlich
genau in die für ihn vorgesehene
aussparung passt dazu
kommt dann hier der deckel drauf machen
dass darüber und dann sieht man die
scheiße so an und dann trägt man das in
dem park aussicht dass für sich zwei
wechsel und wir werden sehen bevor wir
jetzt einmal zur bewertung dieses
bauwerks kommen wir kriegen das bier ja
gar nicht kalt das ist 30 grad draußen
wir können natürlich keinen kühlschrank
mitnehmen und eine kühltasche da passt
der komplette cast nicht werden da
kommen sl eisblock bier kühler endspiel
dieses produkt oder ein ähnliches
produkt war bei höhle der löwen das
eigentlich höhle der löwen produkt ist
mittlerweile ausverkauft kann man nicht
kaufen das ist im prinzip baugleich
tatsächlich wollten die einen ziemlich
anderen dir wollten die lizenzrechte für
20.000 im jahr verkaufen das kam
ziemlich schlecht an ist nicht zu einem
deal gekommen und deswegen gibt es das
eigentliche produkt wahrscheinlich auch
nicht mehr werden das gestern natürlich
schon vorbereitet und in die
tiefkühltruhe getan wir schauen uns
jetzt mal an ob das alles funktioniert
ja das war die rolex
die habe ich übelst dagegen gescheppert
ja was soll's muss irgend jemand darum
kümmert mag
wer das gestern reingetan auch relativ
um gleich aufgegangen aber das ist ja
relativ egal solange es die wirkung hat
und wirklich kühlt zu kaufen ist dieses
produkt für so ziemlich jeden preis also
gibt's auf ebay schon mega günstig für
ein paar euro ich habe jetzt 15 euro auf
amazon bezahlt und angeblich soll das
innerhalb von 30 minuten zehn grad
herunterkühlen was schon richtig gut
wäre das ist gerade auf raumtemperatur
bei wahrscheinlich 25 grad
junge
die scheiße kommt ihr jetzt endlich aus
sie kommt die hier so direkt zwischen
die flaschen so
wunderbar tipptopp das passt also es war
jetzt nicht viel einfacher als hätte ich
einfach bier kaltgestellt und das
einfach im rucksack mit in den park
genommen
ja ich sehe ich aus wie jemand der so
für zwei tage nach köln gekommen ist um
am aachener weiher zu ziehen aber ich
habe die hände frei um tatsächlich ist
es relativ komfortabel also es ist auf
jeden fall 400 mal entspannter als die
kiste in den händen zu tragen ist mir
gerade noch eingefallen ist man muss ja
grundsätzlich nicht mal den kasten
tragen sobald man ein fahrrad hat oder
scooter konto kann man das auch auf
einem dieser fahrzeuge transportieren
apropos fahrrad haben wir dann nicht
auch ein produkt für euch vorbereitet
aber natürlich haben wir ein produkt für
euch vorbereitet converse eickel heißt
das ding auf dem ich hier gerade sitze
und vielleicht seht ihr strom wenn ich
euch jetzt mal noch ein bisschen näher
komme dass sie eigentlich gar keinen
platz für einen kasten bier ist dieses
fahrrad ist ein lastenrad und
gleichzeitig ein völlig normales fahrrad
die leute die lassen fahrradfahren
kennen das problem bis die grundsätzlich
wenn sie mit dem ding unterwegs sind
einlassen parat haben auch wenn sie
nicht transportieren ist eine große box
die man aber er eigentlich nicht immer
braucht es funktioniert so man löst den
kinder unten und dann wenn man hier das
rad
einfach einmal raus klappen das rastet
ein und dann weil sie eigentlich mit am
coolsten finden
kann man das schutzblech auch wieder
festmachen und hat ein vollwertiges
lastenfahrrad also genug platz für einen
tag im park hat man auf jeden jedenfalls
oder wollen wir das ganze mal testen
elektroantrieb auch inklusive beladung
überhaupt kein problem ich kann super
easy fahren ich muss im prinzip gar
nichts machen auf der höchsten stufe
könnt ihr auch relativ enge kurven
fahren selbst mit einer handkamera um
den kasten wir hinten drin alles bestens
mega mega gutes produkt fertig ist es
und wieder ein völlig normales
einsatzbereites fahrrad das waren zwei
handgriffe und vielleicht 30 sekunden
mega mega angefragt hatte conwert
500.000 euro für 15 was einen firmenwert
von 3,3 millionen euro bedeutet hätte
sie haben allerdings keinen deal
bekommen ist vielleicht ein bisschen zu
verstehen die zielgruppe ist schon
relativ schmal gerade mit 2600 euro fürs
normale und mit über 4000 euro für die
elektrische variante ich finde es aber
unheimlich gut wenn ich ein lassen
fahrrad kaufen würde wäre das viel mehr
eine option für mich als ein
lastenfahrrad das ist nicht umbauen
lässt absolutes premiumprodukt gut dass
sie keinen deal bekommen haben da können
die schönen selbstständig weiter machen
einfach weil ich so begeistert bin links
in der video beschreibung finde ich mega
mega geil zu bekommen auf jeden fall
unser bier in den tag und genau da
geht's auch wieder hin die jungs warten
empfahl ich muss schnell los
[Musik]
also dieses produkt hier ist mit abstand
das beste was heute dabei haben scotty
grill deutsches produkt von ihnen dem
abziehen der schlau genug war nicht zur
höhle der löwen zu gehen und glaubt es
mir oder glaubt es - gerade als wir
anfangen wollten zu grillen klingelt
mein handy freuen ich wurde eingeladen
von marius und kellogg's tresor wir sind
in der halle und wir werden heute
challenges ausgesetzt bei dem wir die
möglichkeit haben für euch fette gewinne
zurück
jetzt gemeinsam mal an diesen riesen
kellogg's geworden
banken wiesen pakete zu gewinnen xbox
mix punktuellen franke loks tresor
jahresvorrat und dazu eine oculus kurs 2
alle teilnahmebedingungen findet über
den ersten sieg in der video bestrebung
check-in kellogg's tresor de-interview
im kanal aus und nimmt am gewinnspiel
teil wenn du gewinnst wenn ich gewinnen
und das haben uns jetzt gemeinsam an
über schluchten musste sprang bei bäume
darunter hätten die strecke ist über
einen kilometer
und westen teils sich beim ersten mal
durch man sonst laufe ich im schlimmsten
fall drei kilometer und habe keinen
preis moment
darauf habe ich mich wieder eingelassen
und das alles nur für euch
ich will so ein verdeck
auslaufen
klickt auf den ersten blick der
beschreibung auf kellogg's tresor die
instagram kanal da findet ihr alle infos
wie ihr teilnehmen könnt und staubt eins
von diesen gewinnen dafür liest also
machen mit vielen dank an den tresor
dass sie das video möglich gemacht haben
jetzt wird es weiter mit dem video das
nächste produkt befindet sich an meinem
handgelenk wenn ich jetzt den ganzen tag
im park wäre mit seiner ziemlich helle
haut könnte es sehr schnell dazu führen
dass ich sonnenbrand bekommen und
langfristig führt das dazu dass sich
mein hautkrebsrisiko um ein vielfaches
steigert das ding ist genau dieses
produkt soll dabei abhilfe schaffen es
ist ein produkt das mit einer app
connected ist ein v strahlen misst und
mich davor warnt wenn ich irgendwann aus
der sonne raus soll mich nochmal ein
creme soll und so weiter angefragt
hatten sie 110000 euro für 15 was
733.000 euro firmenwert gewesen werden
bekommen haben sie 110000 euro für 25
prozent was einen film wert von 440.000
euro ergibt hier sind connected wir
sehen dass wenn ich das jetzt hier in
die sonne halten dass sich die werte
verändern und der über den tag hinweg
schon gemessen hat da ist mein uv wert
insgesamt ziemlich niedrig weil ich viel
drin war und man sieht das jetzt ganz
zum ende des diagramms ist immer mehr
wurde weil wir jetzt schon seit 15
minuten park sind an sich muss ich sagen
finde ich jetzt schon eine ziemlich gute
idee die gründer haben einen ziemlich
großen dlr irgendwas raumfahrt preis mit
diesem produkt gewonnen wir schauen nach
her wie gut und wie sicher dass alles
funktioniert für 49 99 nicht ganz
günstig aber für leute die probleme
damit haben mit sicherheit erschwinglich
wir gehen jetzt erst mal wie bekommt man
eigentlich das perfekte fleisch in laut
alexander daniel und tobias fallen nur
mit den bavarian rascher das ding ist
dass sie ist kein bavarian rascher das
hier ist ein ikea teller halter im
prinzip aber genau das gleiche das
problem ist der bavarian rascher oder
der barbecue rascher wir jetzt heißt ist
komplett ausverkauft so oft verkauft das
wir seit 30 tagen nicht die möglichkeit
haben ihn zu bestellen wenn wir ihn per
mail geschrieben hatten keine option
irgendwie dran zu kommen dann habe ich
ein bisschen gegoogelt und die grill
community auf youtube sagt dass das hier
genau das gleiche ist außen kross innen
saftig dafür soll der bavarian rascher
helfen es geht im prinzip darum das
fleisch in eine andere position auf dem
bild zu bekommen anstatt es nur zulegen
wird es nach dem angriff hier
reingestellt sowie jetzt meine hand und
dafür für die nötige kostheim nochmal
nach gericht sie wollten 20 prozent für
50.000 euro bekommen haben 50.000 euro
für 25 von rolf deml wir legen auf dem
grill und schauen ob es funktioniert
legen wir gehen da rein und lassen das
für die nächsten paar minuten noch
ziehen und gucken ob es wirklich
außenpfosten und knusprig wird test ende
des barbecue rescher beziehungsweise
care alternativprodukt also außer hier
bewerber schreibt mir jetzt irgendwie
warum das deutlich besser ist als die c
ker produkt ich sehe überhaupt keinen
unterschied zwischen den beiden
produkten egal wie ihr das fleisch so
auf den grill gestellt bekommt das
ergebnis wird gleich sein und wir hätten
jetzt ob es auch gut ist und ob es
wirklich hält was es verspricht
knusprig ist wirklich wenn es auch noch
schön weich wunderbar habe gerade noch
ein anderes probiert was wir nicht auf
den rechner getan haben so etwas nur lag
also konzept geht auf brot macht keinen
sinn er ist das produkt schon gibt kluge
zu 30 minuten von wir sind jetzt auch
rum also willkommen zum finalen test des
eisblocks
ja das funktioniert tatsächlich also es
richtig richtig ordentlichen
bauchspeck und bier beste also wenn du
jetzt ein bier einfach rechtzeitig im
kühlschrank tust du das denn rucksack
praxisteam wir auch kalk stell dir mal
vor dass die kühlbox und kannst du
einfach alles reinlegen und aktiviert
ein dritter ein
blog für mich ein nahezu winning produkt
es macht nicht besonders viel sinn wenn
man platz hat das ding rumliegen hat
mega gut gestylt und alles bestens der
grill tag ist gerettet aber was wäre ein
schöner grilltag mit den jungs im park
wenn wir das ganze nicht foto und video
mäßig festhalten könnten das problem
drohnen sind mega teuer eine gopro haben
aber viele leute irgendwie zu hause
herum fliegen und genau hier kommt er
ins spiel das ganze ist ein wurf sollen
eine alternative zu drohnen seien im
prinzip ist es dieses teil hier oben
kommt die gopro rein das ganze wird
zusammengeschraubt von einem stuttgarter
startup 750.000 euro dafür zehn prozent
abgeben bekommen haben sie 150.000 euro
haben aber 15 prozent abgegeben das
ganze ergibt einen film wert von einer
million euro das produkt kostet 79 euro
und ob es das wert ist schauen uns jetzt
gemeinsam an jetzt im prinzip wirft man
es einfach
und es fällt zwar auf 1 auseinander
perfect day da kannst du keinem erzählen
wir werfen das mal in richtung der jungs
und es fehlt komplett auseinander
wir haben auf video ob es jetzt richtig
zusammengebaut war ich ziehe alles
zurück komplett meine schuld völlig
verloren ich habe alle pakete
aufgerissen alles in eine tüte
geschmissen alles mit in den park um
mich nicht vernünftig darüber informiert
wie ist eigentlich hätte machen sollen
wenn ich die produkte rechtmäßig testen
möchte und deswegen ist wir haben zwei
wichtige sachen beim wurf fall vergessen
einmal ein kleines distanz etwas dafür
sorgt dass die kamera nicht in dem fall
drin herum schlackert und einmal das
allerwichtigste ein klettverschluss den
man
dahin macht wo man eigentlich packen
würde um das ding komplett fest zu
ziehen und dafür zu sorgen dass es nicht
beim ersten wurf auseinanderfällt dieses
produkt ist für mich ein absolutes
winning produkt ich habe es komplett
selber zerstört das war komplett meine
schuld liebes er tut mir schrecklich
leid er habe ein wunderbares produkt und
es war komplett mein fehler kauft euch
alle er sonst werdet ihr diesen sommer
nicht mehr glücklich bist du ich sagen
ja sorry es tut mir leid ich hab's
komplett verkackt ausgelassener tag im
park geht zu ende alle super drauf gut
gesättigt wir getrunken hier war kalt
alles bestens das problem im sommer
kommt es zum lippen stichen und hier
kommt ins spiel dieses ding verspricht
durch hitze die man direkt über sein
iphone bezieht man steckt das ding quasi
ins iphone rein mückenstichen und jede
art von anderen stichen behandeln zu
können mückenstiche werden aufgeheizt
das ist nicht mehr geheilt aber es wird
warm und dadurch sollen alle negativen
punkte der mückenstiche gelindert werden
die gründer wollten 500 k 14 prozent das
wäre hätte einen film wert von fünf
millionen ergeben bekommen haben sie
keinen deal wir schauen aber ob das
trotzdem funktioniert sie hat nämlich
beim nächsten astra plattform eigener
vorher schon 80.000 euro eingesammelt
wir schauen uns jetzt an ob es
funktioniert ob es hilft und ob ich es
euch für 30 euro empfehlen würde das
hier ist im prinzip das komplette
produkt gibt es auch für android das
steckt man hier dran wir können
einstellen kurze behandlungen mittlere
behandlung lange behandlung kind oder
erwachsener und empfindliche haut stelle
also es wird aufgeheizt und belegen es
zur behandlung drauf sind
wärmer und ist fertig und im prinzip
soll das die komplette behandlung
gewesen sein wir lassen das jetzt mal 5
minuten ruhen und checken dann ob dieses
produkt hält was es verspricht bietet
damit ein jakob mitgegeben der dass wir
die nächsten tage noch weiter getestet
hat und das hier ist sein fazit hallo
für mich war so effektvoll bietet
eigentlich damals zu vergleichen wir uns
nicht ein feuerzeug an die stelle hält
weiß ich jetzt nicht ob das so viel
bringt weg war der schmerz dann auf
jeden fall nicht rita unser uv bodyguard
dem wir jetzt den ganzen tag während des
grillens am arm getragen haben also
tatsächlich er funktioniert er zeichnet
auf wie sehr wir uv strahlung ausgesetzt
sind das ding ist wenn man erwachsenen
ist wenn man ein bisschen darauf achtet
wenn man sich und seine haut
kennengelernt hat über die letzten jahre
sollte man das irgendwann verstehen was
man vom hauttyp ist wie sehr man in der
sonne bleiben kann und so weiter ein
kind unterwegs ist und da vielleicht
nicht richtig einschätzen kann ok wie
lange kann das kind in der sonne bleiben
ist das bestimmt super für mich für 50
euro ein bisschen zu viel weil es auch
kein problem löst das ich selber habe
aber all in all für mich ein gutes
funktionierendes aber für mich unnötiges
produkt unnötig oder nicht scheiß egal
hauptsache wir hatten spaß und wenn ihr
spaß verriet dass wir gerne leichter
vergess ich denken als abonnieren ich
wünsche euch einen wunderbaren sommer
mit dem besten höhle der löwen produkten
die euch den sommer versüßen wir sehen
uns am donnerstag wieder da gibt es im
büro update zu allem was ihr in den
letzten monaten passiert ist ich hoffe
ihr hattet spaß macht's gut cous cous
cous